beaten sense so that's
that's decent at least
okay let's go into more
catalan torture huh just play the main
line for once
rook d1
is this a thing
yeah i will just go b5 he certainly has
some ideas here to
to justify the pawn sack but i'm
at the current moment i'm not that
worried
not sure maybe i'll just go c6
if he takes the pawn i'm fine i think
have a good pawn structure and no
worries and this sort of transposes into
some different lines where black usually
does okay
is 97 reasonable now
could be no knight d7 knight c6 bishop
c6
bishop c6 roxy8 and there's a pin
and if bishop c6 i got queen c8
and i think i'm fine
yeah let's just do it
yeah i'm expecting bishop c6 okay so we
just
it just plays it slowly he's upon down
but he's
judging that he has good compensation
which is more than reasonable let's go
rook c8
knight c5 got knight c5 dc five queen
two seven i think
before there's g5
should be fine for me there should be
two we can play but i'll
continue developing and this bishop
sucks but
i have this square for my pieces
potentially also the knight can go here
so i i mean he has compositional
compensation but i don't think he's
better
and yeah although he loves psychic
material
i think bishop f4 would be too much even
for him
knight d3 on the other hand probably is
a very good move
which i completely missed
yeah now we get this bishop to f4
that's just really really annoying
bishop f4 queen d7 queen goes to e8
i'm solid but this one it's just not
very good
you can go b4 making sure that i never
do this
bishop t2 it's really
really trying to suffocate me
push by five now d
rook d7 hoping to get bishop d8 probably
yeah i have to exchange
probably have to give a give a pawn back
with bishop d8 at some point
i should make some lift for my king so i
don't believe he has anything
concrete at the moment let's go knight
d5
actually just trying to provoke
e4 then i will go back and
then bishop d8
oh maybe you can just prevent it
you can just go queen d3
yeah queen d2
he's playing so well really really well
now i'm just suffocated
turning into one of these games where
us i don't like to say one side is
playing and the other side is just
clapping
i can't do anything but wait at g4 i'm
hoping to have knight h7
97
have to try and hustle him here again
hoping for bishop c7 that i can take
rook d7
oh this this yeah this one i don't think
it's that dangerous
this one i believe is fine for me i just
take and
i don't have anything better so yeah
take
go back then i take on h4
get knight g5 coming i think i'm fine
now
rook effect is a big threat
so he deals with that quite effectively
uh how can i create counterplay
let's go knight e4 c3 to d5 maybe
okay and now rook effect what's this
idea
f5 i think is a bit too much
so tense really really tense
i'll take it
what's this idea i take again
is he just collapsing here now
okay let's go back i don't have that i
don't have that much time
oh i missed this one that was his idea
of course
oof we're just losing now
probably just losing pc7
why why
there is rookie eight now okay
oh sorry that was the wrong button
poor really really poor um i mean in
general they deserve to win in that game
but